bonsoir à vous on voit vaut le coup mais
je crois qu'ils seront transformées
bientôt ça c'est la salle de rédaction
de la presse alors autrement dit pour
vous le papier c'était devenu encombrant
trop cher par rapport aux revenus que
vous pouviez en tirer le modèle
d'affaires des journaux sur un modèle
d'affaires qui est très sain et journaux
repose essentiellement sur deux sources
de revenus les revenus d'abonnements et
les revenus publicité dans les deux cas
comme de 10 g ral depuis l'an 2000
et ça s'est accéléré et normand depuis
2006 elles ont des revenus qui sont
largement en déclin même si une chute
qui est dramatique
ce qui fait en sorte que quand vous avez
uniquement de ceux survenus pivot venu
fonctionne pas il faut trouver un
nouveau modèle d'avion n'avait pas le
choix
quelle est la part des revenus qui
proviennent encore du papier du journal
si je l' inverse ok aujourd'hui dans nos
projections au 31 décembre 75 % nous
revenus publicitaires du bureau vont
venir de la presse plus à ça je peux
ajouter 1 10% qui provenaient de la
presse - série de la presse mais ça
faisait qu'au 31 décembre
il ya 85 % de nos revenus qui vont venir
de nos plateformes numériques dont
principalement la presse plus c'est lui
qui agace uniquement 15% mais parce que
c'était là le grand point
d'interrogation dans tout ça il ya une 5
6 ans quand tous les journaux pas
uniquement la presse réfléchissait à ça
c est ce que les revenus publicitaires
vont suivre sur des plateformes
numériques
ce que les entreprises vont payer autant
d'argent donc est ce que vous faites
autant d'argent que la presse plus que
vous ne le faisait autrefois sans aller
dans des termes très très spécialisé au
monde la vente de publicités dans un
monde numérique se calcule en cpm qui le
coût pour rejoindre mille personnes
l'avantagent de la presse plus c'est
qu'on rejoint une clientèle qui est
jeune cette clientèle là un haut niveau
de revenu et elle nous consacre un temps
de consommation de 40 minutes en moyenne
par jour la semaine on est déjà rendu à
presque à 188 ouverture quotidienne
donc ça que c'est ce que vous
var desservant ça et on a ça fonctionne
ça fonctionne on vend l'engagement ok
donc on essaie pm aujourd'hui le coût
par mini qui est aussi élevé sinon plus
et le dise qu'on avait dans le papier
alors que le cpm de l'internet accepte
actuellement une masse de consommation
et un temps je vous ai donc la forme
modèle fonctionne très bien mais les
gens viennent pour des fractions minutes
par jour très bien combien de gens
croyez-vous vont être abandonnées dans
tout ça des gens qui ne font pas le
passage au numérique pour toutes sur
deir ezzor qui vise la journal sur du
papier qui reste rarement au même on
mène depuis le lancement de la presse
plus qu'on appelle nos jus des études de
migration on mesure exactement ce que je
peux vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que 75%
de nos abonnés la dernière étude de
migration qu'on a fait à la fin du
printemps pour faire des 15% de nos
abonnés s'attendait cette année parce
qu'on arrête le perroquet 25-25 qui ne
s'attendaient pas donc il nous reste 80
mille abonnés papier payant en semaine
nous on calcule piano 35000 qui vont
migrer vers la presse russe
et aucun culte que les autres monnaies
vers nos preuves donc la forme gratuite
d'après ce modèle lapresse.ca ces
ordinateurs parce que on a un contenu
qui est riche des gens des gens aiment
l'adn de l'a13 et je pense que cet adn
là il le retrouve peu ou pas dans les
autres régions et vous dites même s'il
ya une certaine proportion de gens qui
nous suivent ne nous suivent rapport
cinéluctable le changement délectable
coup distribution rire des picots c'est
un débat qu'on peut avoir
qu'on peut tenir mais même pas ce canada
s'est dit aujourd'hui dans une situation
de monopole quoi ce qu'ont fait passer
le prix du timbre bertrand quel que soit
un dallage de son épitaphe en tous les
jours de 6 h les rues du québec - nous a
dit que sont inchangées a fait changer
mais nous on fait encore un petit pied
on livre de moins en moins une copine
aux inscriptions sont élevés donc c'est
un modèle qui peut pas soutenir
maintenant jusque viendrait compléter
c'est qu'on a des programmes ou si on a
même commencé il ya déjà 2 mois de ça on
visait tous les centres de personnes
âgées tous à pied
on a des projets véritable 1
on amène des tablettes et on va voir des
programmes aussi avec des principaux
détaillants que des gens vont être
accueillies chez des marchands pivot
émergents vont les aider pour quelqu'un
de spécialisé qui ont montré comment
dans l'aude et l'application commencé
commencé inscrire auprès d'apple ou des
autres fournisseurs
guy crevier ce que vous engagez à ce que
l'application de la presse plus
demeurent gratuits absolument pour trois
semaines et non absolue
nous notre objectif c'est d'être un
média de masse et moi je pense que la
gratuité en information et quelque chose
d'irréversible
vous avez vendu votre plateforme
technologique au toronto star a commencé
ce lundi france connaît des images
retransmises à pas c'est frappant je
regardais ce lundi on a l'impression que
c'est la presse plus en anglais est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres grands journaux qui
sont en ligne parce que vous c'est des
revenus ça ne va pas il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas un mois qu'on a pas de levier
cette structure est organisée de hauts
dirigeants de groupes soient européens
ou américains qui vient de voir notre
modèle d'affaires parce que des gens
sont très impressionnés je vous dirais
par exemple pour être totalement
transparent avec vous je vous dirais que
une fois qu on présente nos chefs que je
vous disais tantôt nos ouvertures nos
nouveaux revenus que ça des gens sont
ébloui qu'elle a fait certains d'entre
eux ce qui nous dit c'est est-ce que
c'est du un village loin ce que c'est dû
au fait qu'on soit dans un marché
francophone
emilio questionne ce qui est une bonne
question c'est pour ça que la démarche
toronto star pour nous
excessivement important parce que
effectivement des grands groupes de
presse américains et européens qui sont
là qui nous suivent qui nous prend
régulièrement qui ont dès qu'ils
développent par modèle d'affaires basé
sur notre stratégie est qui et qui
évolue d'apremont devrait être en mesure
d'annoncer le très bonne nouvelle aux
côtés d'autres gr jean nohain terminaux
monsieur crevier bref si vous
réfléchissez à ça depuis plusieurs
années vous les journaux régionaux d'air
par la compression
ah ouais je le dirai donnez a vendu en
novembre
les journaux régionaux parce que ce
modèle là d'affaires n'est pas évident
en numérique par tout ce qui le met
finalement le modèle le modèle
d'affaires de la presse plus c'est un
modèle qui est bâti sur un contenu une
présentation excessivement riche donc il
ya besoin d'avoir nous on pense que
c'est un modèle d'affaires qui
s'applique aujourd'hui à des salles de
nouvelles si on peut certes un niveau en
termes d'effectifs il y les grands
parents organisent des arts organise de
presse
est ce qu'un jour on aura une
application ou ce qu'on appelle une
habitation light ou déjà un qui vous
permettra avec des outils de
productivité plus développé un à des
journaux avec moins de serrage ou moins
d'effectifs de migrer probablement mais
c'est pendant le week-end très bien le
samedi on se quitte là dessus le samedi
vous conservez le papier à la grosse
presse du samedi avec quelque chose de
ces le dernier symbole nous combien de
temps on espère le plus longtemps
possible parce qu'on a quand même de
chaque samedi on a quand même 35
personnes se procure l'adresse papilles
dans les chais décidé à des canaris a
fait céder ou l'imprimerie a gardé des
imprimeries mais doté primaires c'est sa
responsabilité de rentabilisation des
années son opération et on est dans un
environnement de distribution qui est
très différent il y aura des pertes
d'emplois à ce ne pouvait pas les
chiffres et aujourd'hui je ne veux pas
je suis aujourd'hui par respect pour nos
employés que j'ai rencontrés aujourd'hui
remplir les premiers nos employés des
rencontres avec le détail des pertes
d'emplois
j'ai eu dix prochains centres à plaisir
de revenir si vous messieurs gravier
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup